est cela fait deux ans que le tram de
tours a été inauguré deux ans jour pour
jour
on se souvient de ces images que vous
allez voir cette grande inauguration une
émigration grande pompe avec la présence
du premier ministre manuel valls et du
président de l'agglomération de l'époque
jean germain
deux ans plus tard le transport ferré a
connu un véritable succès de
fréquentation soixante mille voyageurs
par jour en moyenne en 2015 contre 55
milles en 2014
une fréquentation qui en 2014 était déjà
au delà des espérances et en deux ans le
tram de tours a connu aussi quelques
déconvenues
on peut même parler de loi des séries
souvenez vous cette personne qui avait
propulsé sa voiture sur une rame pour se
suicider il y a eu le feu de cesse de
cet été et puis dernier événement en
date c'était samedi le déraillement
d'une rame dans le quartier du sanitas à
tours il a fallu de nombreuses heures
pour la remettre sur les rails et ce à
l'aide d'une grue à nice une chose un
rail creusés dans la terre
voilà la dernière péripétie du tramway
en deux ans de bons et loyaux services
ce samedi 29 août 2015 vers 16h une rame
des rails le conducteur à la proche de
la station liberté terminus provisoire
de la ligne s'aperçoit qu'une autre rame
est déjà à quai il entame donc une
marche arrière mais la tête de la ram a
déjà passé l'aiguillage qui a commuter
entre temps résultat la wampas sur
l'autre voie quand l'arrière reste sur
la même
le tram se retrouve donc en portefeuille
pour remettre la rame sur les rails
il faut faire appel à une grue pendant
quelques minutes le tram est suspendue
au dessus du sol une opération très
délicate
c'est une opération complexe et longue
et surtout qu'il fallait doucement une
rame c'est comme c'est comme une caisse
de voiture c'est fragile vous avez
châssis en alu et donc il faut pouvoir
il faut pouvoir qu'elles restent
complètement intègre
l'opération aura duré jusque tard dans
la nuit mais ce n'est pas la première
fois que le train ne déraille
souvenez vous le 11 avril 2014 un
automobiliste lancé à vive allure
percute le tramway avant que sa voiture
s'embrase
la scène se passe le midi place jean
jaurès sous les yeux ébahis des
tourangeaux l'automobiliste 17 dans les
flammes
on apprendra après qu'il avait tout
planifié
l'homme avait en effet annoncé à son ex
femme qu'il souhaitait brûlé place jean
jaurès bilan quatre passagers
hospitalisés le conducteur de la rame en
état de choc et des passants médusés
ce suicide sera donc en deux ans le seul
accident mortel impliquant le tramway
mais le tram est aussi un symbole de la
ville c'est pourquoi le 20 octobre 2014
les salariés du restaurant la casa de
leur tranquille qui ne sont plus payés
depuis la fermeture de l'établissement à
cause d'un sinistre choisissent d'en
bloquer la circulation pendant une
vingtaine de minutes
rebelote le 19 mai 2015 où cette fois ce
sont les gens du voyage qui font
pression pour pouvoir installer plus de
160 caravanes sur la plaine de la
gloriette pour un rassemblement
évangélique
enfin impossible d'oublier lincendie du
pont ferroviaire de l'avenue de grammont
dans la nuit du 10 au 11 juillet 2015
un incendie de grande ampleur qui aura
fait partie en fumée les câbles de
précontrainte installé sous le tablier
pour le renforcer et permettent la
circulation des trams le pont étant
fragilisés la circulation normale ne
reprendra qu'en novembre 2015
c'est l'incident qui aura le plus
perturbé le fonctionnement du tramway